وفي اليوم الثالث تسرب اسمه عبر مصادر
الصحافه العبريه وعرف الناس من يكون رغم
التكتم المشدد على هويته فتعالت صيحات
الفخر ومعها عبارات الدعاء الى الله
ليشمله برحمته على السنوف المصريين والعرب
كما تكدست صوره على حسابات رواد الاعلام
الاجتماعي في المساحه الشاسعه الممتده من
المحيط الى الخليج حتى بات محط الانظار
بوصفه رمزا وطنيا وقوميا ولد محمد صلاح
الشاب المصري الذي قتل السبت الماضي ثلاثه
جنود اسرائيليين قبل ان يقتله اخرون منهم
في عين شمس قرب العاصمه المصريه القاهره
عام 2001 او وفق حساب زمني اخر بعد مرور
ازيد من عقدين على اتفاقيات كام ديفيد
التي ابرمتها مصر مع اسرائيل عام
1978 وكان من المفترض ان تنهي الحرب وترسي
عهد السلام والتعاون والتطبيع بين الانظمه
كما بين الشعوب هو ليس الاول طبعا الذي
يقدم على عمل فردي فيربيك حسابات اقليميه
ويفرض اعاده النظر الجدي فيما ظنه بعض
قاده المنطقه والعالم او صنفوه في قائمه
منجزاتهم على طريق تغيير التاريخي قبله
كان هناك اخرون اقدم على فعل مماثل اشهرهم
المصري سليمان خاطر الذي قتل مجموعه من
الاسرائيليين في سيناء عام 85 فاعتقل
ليحاكم محاكمه عسكريه ثم قيل انه مات
منتحرا في زنزانته وكذلك الاردني احمد
الدجامسه الذي نفذ عمليه مشابهه عام 97 اي
بعد ثلاث سنوات من ابرام معاهده السلام
بين بلاده واسرائيل فاعتقل وحكم عليه
بالسجن المؤبد ثم اطلق سراحه بعد مرور 20
عاما
[تصفيق]
لكن هناك فرقا يستدعي التامل بين عمليه
محمد صلاح وعمليات السابقيه من الجنود
العرب الذين تمردوا على السلام الرسمي بين
دولهم واسرائيل كان سياق السنوات التي
سبقت عبور الجنديه المصري الشاب تحصينات
عسكريه معقده ليقتل الجنود الاسرائيليين
الثلاثه قد اكتسم بتفشي تطبيع مع اسرائيل
في اجزاء عده من العالم العربي رغم اتجاه
الدوله اليهوديه كما تسمى نفسها نحو
التطرف او حتى العنصريه في راي كثيرين
واستمرارها بل امعانها في شن الحروب
المتكرره على الشعب الفلسطيني وقمعه وقتله
وتهويد مقدساته بينما كان سياق الهجومين
المشابهين الذين نفذهما خاطر والدجامسه
يتمثل في انهما جاء حين كان النظام الرسمي
العربي عموما ما زال على بعض حياء او تردد
في القبول بفكره دمج اسرائيل في نسيج
المنطقه ويتمسك ولو ظاهريا بما كان يسمى
مبدا الارض مقابل السلام اي رفض الاعتراف
بدوله الاحتلال ما لم تنفذ قرارات الشرعيه
الدوليه التي تقضي بانسحابها من الاراضي
المحتله عام 1967
مجددا سيكتشف دعاه السلام او التطبيع
المجاني والحال هذه ان قرابه نصف قرن من
سعيهم الحفيف لتغيير مسار التاريخ بما
يلبي شروط القوات التي غيرت الجغرافيا لم
تبدل شيئا في المزاج الشعبي العربي العربي
الذي مازال اسرائيل دوله احتلال عنصري
ويعتقد بان عليها دفع الثمن عن كل ما
اقترفات طال الزمن او قصر